why does she feel like my skinny hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot one it's the show of hot questions
even hotter Wayne and today I'm joined
by keke palmer
you know her from scream queens she
recently released a memoir i don't
belong to you and you can catch her in
the upcoming second season of Berlin
station Kiki welcome to the show thank
you for having me
how are you with hot food I love that
food I just said to zantac so you know
I'm prepared for this that's a veteran
move Kiki that's a veteran move what we
did bring you wings but the gag is that
are covered an extremely hot sauce are
you ready to get it going
I'm de-rate
and then the
so the first one is sriracha
sriracha's no big deal mm-hmm so I want
to start by talking about my favorite
keke palmer song and video got me tapped
up because it plays on this idea of
people under estimating your savage side
so too can you give me a time in your
life or in your career where somebody
tried you and had to find out the hard
way how real you can be oh my gosh it's
happened a jillion times I think of the
level of savagery I can actually let you
all into you can go there okay the hot
wing chicken show it's not it's not it's
not that big of a deal you know what I
mean but you have to you a suit guy
right I'm a very chill type of girl not
over extravagant I'm not extra you know
me I'm very just very chill I think a
lot of times guys will think that I
might be that way when they meet me so
much so that they think they can just
start playing games and being all types
of ways now realizing that I don't have
time to have other places to be I come
out in a very light little petty way and
I just saw a picture of you know someone
you knew I was like you know retweet and
quote handsome and the rest is history
I don't go to harder the paint but I'll
let you know I can come for you don't
make me I can come don't make me like
are you I am me down like I don't know
why I'd you danceable
alright so you're very in touch with
internet culture and then to these
pictures of you kind of take on a life
of their own online so what I've done is
I've pulled some of the pictures that
you even mean yourself with so I'll just
show you the picture and you talk it
through this I'm going down the game
first one and probably the most popular
oh okay I love that one I mean now
the perfect time when you know you're
ready to gag someone when you're ready
to just kind of remind somebody what's
going on you want to let somebody know
you're not one to mess with or you want
to remind them that actually it's the
joke's on you
this would be the perfect man cue God
this one's all over that one is like
like a sneaky on the sly like I bet you
didn't know I could come at you like
that kind of vibe it's similar to the
gag but not really it's like there's a
card up your sleeve
eggs-actly know you know that you didn't
know this one is used a lot to talk to
me about this business I've sold a one
because this is me to the goddamn tea
baby okay I'm not going out the
Millennial guy these days but they want
girls to chase them damn but it's like
girls want to be you know worshipped you
gotta just show girl some love be
romantic sellers should look nice that's
just thirsty for her and it maybe you'll
be able to get the kind of relationships
that you want but guys I'm putting
enough out there you're not thirsty
enough you're not thirsty and if I need
two-thirds I need to be thirsty honey
firstly like I'm about to be after these
hot wings
Patti ain't gonna be none major getting
cocky I love it just that's perspective
so you have an IMDB page that's about a
mile long I feel like I could ask you
about a million different projects but I
do want to focus this wing on one
project in particular it's the long shot
a movie that you did with Ice Cube and
notably it's directed by limp Biskit
front me and Fred Durst
yesterday okay it was just very - you
know just like a cool kind of guy and I
mean it was definitely like working you
know with someone your abanda like whoa
and - I don't want to blow too much
smoke Kiki but I would say that I'm the
throwing the fundamentals actually
pretty good and I should know I played a
little high school football
oh that's very impressive there yeah I
totally worked with Astrid any who
actually is still out in Louisiana
Shreveport you know teaching a bunch of
kids down at a school like literally did
the whole drills with me taught me how
to throw about 40 yards so pretty
impressive and a tight spiral and
I mean you guys start amping it up since
I love this I love this
I'm only eaten in like the dam and so
you're a woman with strong perspective
strong opinions and then you open it up
to Van oftentimes with this hashtag ask
Kiki so what I've done is I've pulled
some quandary Xin my own I want to
bounce them off of you and just get the
best Kiki in second did that sound good
sounds good how do I get more people to
watch my youtube videos be yourself
don't be trying to think about doing
stuff that is perceived as cool online
just think about doing whatever it is
separates you what makes you an
individual my chakras are out of whack
what do I do
chakras are out of whack okay girl this
is not a major deal all we have to do is
check on the food we did eating I've
been having too much calcium and I got
because that always brings a little
nervousness and then also makes you
incorporate that meditation makes you
incorporate that yoga and take your ass
to church on Sunday you need to be with
the people how do I become a god rip
renewer Oh what kind of a nervous but
in your local region alright the
next one is the hot one sauce you're on
the hot one show this is our hot sauce
and here's the thing Kiki if you don't
like this hot sauce I think it is gonna
be a walk in the park for you because we
have like a little bit of a sweeter
sauce but okay I'm curious about your
opinion on this one I know you'll give
it to me real I like the flavoring it is
[Music]
definitely not blowing me back hot but
it definitely wound me back in flavor so
when I was in college for a semester I
ended up living with 11 sorority girls
at one point and in addition to your
role on scream queens you had some
real-life sorority experience of your
own ah yes yes so I did have a bit of a
mini sorority of years I was Howard
University when I was like 9 17 years
old with my mentors when I got there the
girls were not feeling me and so as a
very like typical you know situation
where you're coming in on people's crew
in there
and it's like you're not kind of invited
to the scenario so it was definitely
weird and out do you know surrounding
for me but other than that I had a black
school and I still have a lot of love
aka that one's a little hot sorry not
really not but it's a little hot that's
good cuz I was a little worried about
disappointing you Kiki the way that you
breeze through those first five yeah I'm
afraid you guys might so I'm sure that
they're a handful of our viewers that
recognize you from some of your more
early roles like True Jackson VP yeah it
sure does it'd be yours that winner but
I want to take the spotlight off of you
for a second and focus it on some of the
other iconic teen shows and I just want
to get your snap reactions to it yes you
like that I loved it all right
Moishe what talk to me about Moesha
Moesha is the culture it is everything a
classic great coming of age everything a
family show funny dramatic learning
experience awesome
what about Degrassi Wow Degrassi yo de
Graaff it was so educational and so
dramatic it had so much drama very young
teen soap did you do a guest spot I'm
suggesting I did actually didn't do get
spot of the graph through the second
generation did you miss drink or did you
meet drink or did you so it's actually
funny the gag is Drake was actually the
person that took us on our tour like the
first time and the second time and so I
met him before he actually you know
became his music sensation even though
he was doing music all that time and it
was so funny because I just remember
being like you know the biggest Degrassi
fan this is Dom B apocalypse and I don't
want to oversell it I don't want to get
too cocky but I feel like this is where
it's going to ramp up for you a little
bit okay Kiki
[Music]
here's a little hot it ain't taking me
nowhere for real
Wow look at this
so you're coming off a time where you
did a lot of book signings isn't and
you're at comic-con those seem like the
hottest of hot beds for Bazaar at the
very least very memorable celebrity fan
interactions when you thing because I'm
sweating slightly that's all know is
that hot to me really
my body is responding you said it wasn't
taking you anywhere it is it is no Kiki
oh this is hilarious you guys got to
have something up your sleeve did you
just do this every week you think you're
out here doing that I feel like the
wheels are coming off of my whole like
my whole wave you know what I mean I
have to do this every week I feel like
it's slowly like taking me out it slowly
straighten your heart burn must be
ridiculous mm-hmm bizarre field
interaction what's the prize of knees
well somebody is completely and utterly
introverted in their life you know they
come to the signing or something like
that I'm like hey how you doing girls
good happy you hair thank you did you
enjoy the book
[Music]
I wasn't feeling it definitely got me
lightly it doesn't have me majorly I'm
not yeah because it he likes it here I
thought it was in wait this is like yeah
totally like for a while I'm just
Ricinus mucus you know it's just milk
milk helps milk Oh bring it back down I
made it I want to talk about one of your
favorite topics now astrology when
mercury is in retrograde how if at all
does it affect your life will change the
activities as change your mood so I
don't really get to down to the too much
of the specifics as far as the horoscope
daily activities we don't really every
day I'm more so into what they're saying
the personality breakdown is let me give
you three celebrities okay okay two of
them are virgos one of them is not I
want you to try to pinpoint the one who
is not okay okay Beyonce Kobe Bryant the
rock well Kobe Bryant not Kobe Bryant
the Leo I think wait did I mess this up
Beyonce we all wear them hold on I think
I might a mess she wears it well you
know what so here's the deal I think I
might have messed this up Kobe's a Leo
and he's obviously a little Bryant
birthday but if he's a Virgo even better
okay so he was August 23rd oh no he's a
Fargo man forego it all makes sense
come on tell me why cuz he said you
study it for sure weren't any okay
Beyonce Mother Teresa
in every field we've got it keke palmer
come on you saturday
so this is mad dog 357 there's our
second husband number me
oh that's a good question and very
rarely can I ever answer the questions
that our guests ask though is like all
the Scoville scale what does that mean
all that stuff right I never know any of
the answers but there's a unit of
measurement called the Scoville scale
and that's what measures Heat
so this is three hundred and fifty seven
thousand Scoville units that's where the
three five seven if you must know Kiki
you can learn it I'll tell you that
ain't gonna be nothing look at you I'm
protecting my throat for long
[Music]
how much is okay with you oh good okay
so as we touched out already you have an
IMDB page a mile long and you've been in
this industry since you're nine years
old most of your life in fact what's
your best advice for how to get the best
of greedy executives and hangers-on so
that they don't get the best of you I'm
just filling it for you you have to
always remember who you are as always
what it is you want
why did you know Mia keratin treatment
I think it's fair thank you a lot of
talk early and early on you know what I
mean this is all again I'm doing it
they're coming up I was doing it for
Tommy on Cates now that's all of it that
was all for comedy I'm not really hot oh
that was a joke I'm doing it spin anyway
to point out is make up a five-sided do
it all them guilt yeah I don't know Joe
what you know the industry it will make
you believe that you have to be other
people but the reality is you can be
yourself as long as you remember what it
is you came into the industry for being
a manager engines can never deter you
and bring it to the direction that's not
sure to who you are all right Kiki
[Music]
we have one wing left to go and we are
now to the final hot sauce
it is Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage it's tradition around here to put a
little extra dab on the last wing you
don't have to do if you don't want to I
just do like a little little add a
little bad like a little extra you don't
have to if you don't want to keke palmer
don't have to don't make me seem like
I'm a whip whoa oh all right
even though that's a little less you're
you're bouncing it and they can make me
nervous that you're gonna is that enough
that's not good that's a piece of hair
easy
I get nervous for people we've had we
have people come in here and they're
like and then they're like a little
reckless with it and then they like glob
their last wing and then I'm like he's
like a thing after this you know what I
mean like I missed a bit the bat okay um
I would say who handled it the best
maybe yg gainin well he was telling me
that he goes to wing stop he gets atomic
wings and then he dips them and it was
acting sauce but I'm sitting across and
like right now like Kiki I would say
this yeah and you're handling it right
now
way better than our average guest okay
but I was sitting across from yg and he
was like no big deal he was not a you
know he was like he was mad at us for
not making him Hobbit are you kidding me
no joke no joke so yg was great uh Tommy
Chong jtro all these people keke palmer
GG palmer definitely Kiki Kiki out Ted
hmm top five just take this land all
right
Cheers I really appreciate you for
letting me come on here I appreciate you
for coming in and eating chicken wings
and answering my questions the phone gag
yes I enjoy are you sure you don't
regret it I worry about down I didn't go
out why does she feel like my skin ate
it
why was my skin on fire where is your
skin on fire right here must get it
burning be there it bird hear you bird I
don't know I don't know that would be a
new thing but listen we've had people go
places you're now going somewhere aren't
you now interesting hot sauce it plays
tricks mm-hmm and speaking of tracks
that would be a waste of a keke palmer
interview if we did not talk about the
gag is your signature phrase as a gag is
I love it when I see on Twitter the gag
is I love it when you're on excuse
late-night shows you're doing the gag is
so what I want to do the tab little gag
is off okay
I'll hit you with a little gag is joke
then you hit me with a little gag is
joke and then the first one to run out
of gag is jokes loses does that sound
good all right okay all right I just
took a dab of Blair's Megadeth sauce
with liquid rage the gag is I have to do
it because this is the only real thing
cooking in my career right now I'm
sweating like a hound but the gag is I
didn't exercise I'd say some hot wings I
thought that this would be a good idea
but the gag is I have a little hot sauce
in my windpipe right now and it's
getting kind of difficult to talk so I
won't challenge you to go any further
keke you made it through you cleared the
board look at you my old personal fan
Wow so glamorous so elegant keke this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
yo wish your girl Keke Palmer you can
check me on the second season of Berlin
station I'm getting ready to travel to
Berlin right now to become a spy and you
can also check me on all my social at
keke palmer on twitter and at ke ke and
instagram don't forget about snapchat at
ke e ka
in ke ke th HSN tak and just anywhere
else
there's a girl geeks you love you always
[Music]
you
walking account you guys watch your
hands me was extremely hot yeah hey
what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you like the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend